[Music]
some of us
like a good scratch and
some of us like to pick our noses
why do we even have these things
how would our grip be affected without
them
and how could not having fingernails
improve our health this
is what if and here's what would happen
if humans
didn't have fingernails
fingernails are one of the reasons why
primates are
different from other mammals they're
like the claws you might
find on other mammals only flattened
on average your fingernails grow at a
rate
of almost three and a half millimeters
per month
your toenails only grow half as fast
but what if one day your nails
stopped growing altogether how would
this
change your life your nails
are made of three layers of keratin
keratin cells undergo a form of
programmed cell death
to create the hard form that makes up
your nails
the three layers start soft and get
progressively harder
and together they create a protective
shield
human nails have led to a booming
industry of nail care
products and services in 2020
the global nail care market was
estimated to be worth
2.7 billion dollars
but nail care isn't the reason we have
nails
archaeologists believe that around two
and a half million years ago
our ancestors developed broader
fingertips
it was also around that time that they
started picking up stone
tools but it's still not clear if these
two important evolutionary developments
are linked
claws are good for scratching climbing
and digging holes but fingernails are
critical for being able to do delicate
movements
have you ever thought about how you can
separate pages in a book or
pick up small items like a coin it's
because we have nails
it might not seem like nails have much
sensation but
underneath that hard shell is an
intricate
network of nerves you can grip large
things with your hands and
pick up small thin objects too it's a
perfect balance
the evolution of grooming claws has come
from
thoughts that as our nails got smaller
and smaller
we could more easily groom ourselves and
each other
and that led to more social bonding
it's cool to think that even now getting
your nails done is
still a form of social bonding which we
can trace back
millions of years in our evolution but
if you didn't have nails how would it
affect your health
well it would be good and bad one of the
reasons you have fingernails is
to keep viruses and bacteria from
getting into your body
so if you didn't have nails you would
get sick more often
but that would also mean that less dirt
or bacteria could get
trapped underneath your nails in the
first place which can cause
all sorts of infections you'd be
surprised to learn that
fingernails have another health-related
use
they work as indicators for certain
health conditions
without them it would be harder for you
to check for sickness immediately
for instance peeling nails might signal
an iron deficiency
or horizontal ridges on the nails might
indicate
kidney disease i said might
don't listen to people on the internet
go to your doctor to seek medical advice
if we didn't have nails our everyday
lives would be very different
imagine not being able to pick up small
objects so easily
or having to be more careful because you
might pick up an
infection worst of all you might miss
out on the joy of
getting your nails done and while you're
in the beauty salon
imagine that you didn't have hair and
that everyone was bald it's a little
hair-raising
to think about so let's save this story
for another what if